bonjour ghislaine
lancé pour la chanson vraiment très très
connue très populaire chez point view
keith sherin est poursuivi qu'est ce
qu'on lui reproche exactement
deux raisons ce succès planétaire record
devant istres ou comprendre ces quelques
chiffres une pendant la chanson mon dos
me répète quatre notes deux fois il dit
why why why et il ya deux
compositeurs il a poursuivi faisant ils
nous ont copiés nous deux ans auparavant
on a composé une chanson ou du hoyoux
ouailles dans un autre réel mais on lui
avait envoyé sur twitter alors on est
plage il donc ce que je vous dise qui
est un procès de 3 semaines pour quatre
notes de musique répéter way sur la
version démo qui quand même risque de se
retrouver dans plusieurs chansons dans
le monde entier bon ça se passe en
angleterre cette affaire là mais je
présume que les règles en ce qui
concerne les accusations de plagiat ça
devait se ressembler qu'est-ce qu'il
faut prouver pour qu'un tribunal conclut
a du plaisir justement tous ses feux
dans les mêmes règles en matière de
droit d'auteur ou est tout à fait
d'abord vous prouvez l'axé la personne
qui dit j'ai été copiés doit prouver que
l'autre axe six mois je compose une
chanson en fin de semaine six mois plus
tard un an plus tard j'entends lady gaga
qui chante quelque chose il ressemble un
petit peu pendant quelques notes ben là
on est dans la coïncidence musicale
ensuite il faut prouver que c'est quand
même assez original ça sera pas deux
trois notes ou la gamme de 12 et que ce
qui copiait banques les deux il ya quand
même une similitude important et c'est
souvent seul qui le débat se transforme
en ici qu'ont constitué bon alors je
présume que ed sheeran se défend
qu'est-ce qu'il dit pas lui dis d'abord
je recevais à l'époque des tweets des
centaines par jour je n'ai jamais
entendu cette chanson là avant d'être
poursuivi
si j'avais voulu emprunter un exprès je
l' ai déjà fait pour d'autres chansons
j'aurais donné crédit aux auteurs donc
née en plus honnêtement ces quelques
notes là elles sont assez communes et ça
c'est intéressant la semaine dernière en
plein qu il a chanté ça fait
amusant il a chanté jane à simone qui
est une simone qui est une chanteuse
américaine
notamment de jazz pour dire il ya
vraiment des similitudes dans plein
d'autres chansons de ces quelques bons
pourquoi ça nous arrive pas nous ici en
plein tribunal et gérone qui chantent en
fait il ya eu d'autres cas récemment il
ya eu celui de katie perry qui s'est
réglée ya pas longtemps ah oui tout à
fait ça s'est réglé la semaine dernière
a été condamné à plus de 2 millions et
on avait pour but la cohorte qui est une
chanson très populaire la cour d'appel
vient de lui donner raison
il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas plagie
bon ça c'est réglé ici au québec
guylaine s comme un autre des quatre
plages a évidemment tout le monde pense
ben je vais vous suggérer que tout le
monde pense à la sphère claude robinson
mais en matière de chanson ou d'artistes
qui composent des auteurs compositeurs
et oui il y avait poursuivi en trop de
marie chantal toupin et pour sa chanson
soirée filles soit un album très connu
mais deux chansons commencé par un appel
téléphonique les deux par les turpitudes
mais le juge vraiment comparer
d'expliquer qu'il y avait pas plagier
est super intéressant c'est un plagiat
de mots c'est rien à voir avec la
musique est ce qu'il y avait à peu près
en commun restaient le port de jeans
serrés et juge dit bob et ça c'est pas
suffisant pour décider qui est du
plagiat mais déjà aussi poursuivie au
québec cindy on l'est jean jacques
goldman pour la chanson prière païenne
il avait plaidé que jean jacques goldman
l'avait déjà composée bien avant les
gens de joliette qu'il poursuivait donc
oui il ya quelques semaines
j'imagine qu'avec toutes les plateformes
des côtes où tout est accessible à tout
le monde on doit citer une hausse de ces
recours là
tout à fait je pense aux états unis je
pourrais vous lire le bottin des
chanteurs populaires initiateurs
beaucoup beaucoup de poursuites parce
que l'axé dont je vous ai parlé c'est
plus facile avec les plateformes de mon
espèce sur spotify vous avez
probablement entendu
je vais trahir mon âge mais avant dans
certains cas il fallait prouver qu'on
avait envoyé la cassette en gérant de la
chanteuse le rhône était en état des
zones industrielles
ouest le village ciel des compagnies qui
même font de la recherche vient de voir
et je pense que quelqu'un te plage et
moyennes une commission
pour suivre au tribunal en votre nom et
on peut imaginer non mais tout ça est
très très instructif merci beaucoup
ghislaine bâche un
au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]